[Musique]
bonjour François Bayrou bonjour merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin Emmanuel Macron
devait annoncer par sa première ministre
demain les annonces les arbitrages sur
la réforme des retraites ce sera
finalement a-t-il dit le 10 janvier on a
tout évoqué pour les raisons de ce
report les élections des nouveaux
présidents de parties les hésitations
sur le fond la crâne d'un mouvement
social à Noël le foot quelle est à votre
connaissance la raison de ce report
ce qui me paraît le plus probable
c'est que le Président de la République
a voulu
que le temps de la discussion
et le temps de l'information des
Français parce que pour moi on ne doit
pas déconnecter l'un de l'autre je
dirais même que le temps de
l'information des Français est plus
important pour moi que le temps de la
concertation
c'était votre souhait ce report j'ai
toujours pensé qui fait qu'on n'était
pas à quelques jours près pour une
réforme qui doit concerner les décennies
qui viennent et que on ne fait pas de
réforme si le peuple si les citoyens ne
sont pas dans une situation positive à
l'égard de la règle donc on peut dire
que vous allez penser quel âge non je ne
dis pas qu'ils approuvent nécessairement
mais je dis qu'ils comprennent que qu'il
entre dans l'esprit de tous ceux qui
sont après tout les responsables du pays
ce qui ce qui vote l'esprit civique
qu'ils comprennent l'enjeu et que au
fond de même ils
que cet enjeu et ses décisions sont
nécessaires est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment si on décale ces trois
semaines et demi en fait entre temps il
y a la fin de la coupe du monde de foot
les vacances de Noël le repos aussi des
uns et des autres est-ce que vous pensez
que début janvier quand on sera
peut-être dans une période marquée par
des coupures d'électricité assurément
dans une période où il y aura des
hausses des tarifs de gaz d'électricité
la prédisposition de la société sera
plus favorable vous ne m'avez pas laissé
aller au bout de ma phrase donc ce
premier aspect on a besoin du temps pour
que la concertation soit aussi
développée que possible on va y arriver
pour que la formation des Français
puisse passer puisse diffuser et
deuxièmement il faut que la réforme soit
prête qu'elle soit équilibrée que on
sache qu'elle soit presque aujourd'hui
je dis pas ça je dis que vous voyez bien
que les discussions avec par exemple les
partenaires sociaux
n'ont pas totalement abouti on va dire
ça comme ça avec
de vie hier soir quelques heures avant
votre venue sur ce plateau
l'intersyndical a publié un nouveau
communiqué avec la signature de très
organisation syndicale et de jeunesse
dont la CFDT le titre est très simple
retraite près et déterminé ça se résume
en deux infos un ils sont toujours
opposés sur le fond à un décalage de
l'âge et deux ils disent qu'une fois les
annonces faites ils prépareront une
réponse commune de mobilisation il y a
un risque de mouvement social unitaire
François
des risques vous gouvernez en fonction
de ce que vous pensez être
nécessaire pour le pays vous avez vu que
le plan a publié sous ma responsabilité
une note qui donne les chiffres réels
votre de la situation du pays de la
situation des retraites le chiffre réel
de la situation des retraites c'est que
au contraire de ce qu'on entendait
souvent qui était de dire mais il y a le
feu s'est équilibré et même cet
excédentaire vous avez entendu ce et au
lieu de cet excédent nous avons montré
je crois de manière indiscutable que
c'est en fait un déficit annuel de 30
milliards d'euros 30 milliards d'euros
c'est 30 000 millions d'euros 30
milliards d'euros c'est à dire
l'équivalent du budget de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche vous êtes dans
un scénario je précise plus noir en
réalité que ce qu'avait dit le conseil
d'orientation non je ne suis pas dans un
scénario plus noir ça n'est pas un
scénario les chiffres et la réalité les
chiffres que j'annonce c'est que vos
auditeurs ou vos spectateurs peuvent
retrouver sur
plan.fr qui est le site du
Haut-Commissariat au plan ces chiffres
là sont les chiffres même du corps
mais pourtant vous voyez que les
syndicats il vous entendent ils vous
lisent ils vous écoutent ils se
mobiliseront quand même ils se
mobiliseront mal ceci est autre chose
il me lisent il m'écoute il ne
contredisent pas ce que j'ai dit mais
simplement ils disent nous nous
choisissons de ne pas bouger sur la
retraite je pense que ça n'est pas
raisonnable on est un pays qui est en
déficit chronique déficit très important
et le déficit c'est de la dette comme
vous savez et tout le monde sent le
poids de ce déficit de cette dette et
les retraites contribuent ou participent
pour 30 milliards d'euros à ce déficit
là annuel et ce que dit y compris ces
instances le corps par exemple c'est que
ça va s'aggraver dans les années qui
viennent ce message vous le faites et
vous faites l'oeuvre de pédagogie pour
les français pour qu'ils comprennent la
raison de la réforme c'est effectivement
de votre point de vue un élément
important pour pour autant dès lors que
les syndicats la CFDT en particulier qui
est un syndicat réformiste vous dit on
ne veut pas d'un report de l'âge légal
est-ce que vous dites on peut et on doit
trouver un accord avec la CFDT et
trouver le bon outil ou à minima
peut-être faire un pacte de
non-agression donner des garanties sur
d'autres sujets vous dites
on doit trouver je pense qu'on peut
trouver
un accord plus général
une démarche de bonne volonté et je
pense que c'est même la responsabilité
de ceux qui
sont
soit dans l'exécutif soit dans
législatif parce que le Parlement va
jouer un rôle très important là-dedans
et avoir un projet présenté par le
Gouvernement et le Parlement derrière je
suis sûr va essayer de l'améliorer
d'ouvrir des portes vers un accord plus
large mais il faudrait atteindre un
accord plus large il faudra aussi
trouver un accord au Parlement ça veut
dire une majorité au Parlement le but à
atteindre
ça n'est pas de trouver un accord avec
des interlocuteurs le but à atteindre
c'est d'avoir une stratégie de
rééquilibrage des dépenses du pays et
des dépenses de la retraite entre le
moyen et la fin la fin c'est vrai
équilibrage le moyen c'est peut-être un
accord avec la CFDT sur le plan syndical
avec LR sur le plan politique si on peut
trouver cet accord avec le grand courant
réformiste
auquel j'appartiens et c'est un grand
courant large
avec des inspirations qui viennent d'un
bord de l'autre et du centre
si ce courant trouve un accord ça sera
bien pour le pays pour dire les choses
clairement vous souhaitez qu'il y a un
accord avec les républicains à
l'Assemblée pour voter je souhaite qu'il
y ait l'accord le plus large possible je
ne suis plus proche des positions du
gouvernement non je n'ai pas un
strabisme divergent je ne regarde pas de
préférence vers la droite ou de
préférence
je parle pas de la nupette je pense
qu'il y a des élus
à gauche ou qui viennent de la gauche
qui savent très bien qu'il faut faire
cette écoutez nous avons actuellement un
texte qui régit les retraites c'est la
réforme Touraine quel était le
gouvernement
socialiste socialiste
et ce gouvernement là vous croyez que
les régions qu'on fait faire la réforme
ont changé et vous croyez que la
situation s'est améliorée depuis ce
texte vous dites quelque chose de très
important la réforme Touraine François
Bayrou c'était l'allongement de la durée
de cotisation et non pas le report de
las légal est-ce à vos yeux aujourd'hui
la meilleure solution le but à atteindre
c'est le rééquilibrage est-ce qu'on y
arrive par la durée de cotisation si on
a
un scénario crédible si on avait
un scénario crédible de rééquilibrage
par
uniquement la durée de cotisation je
trouverais ça positif est-ce que ce
scénario existe et bien c'est ce que
c'est ce qu'on va voir on va avoir des
scénarios sous les yeux le Parlement va
se mettre en route ce que disent les
experts que j'entends c'est que ça ne
suffira pas si je dis que et que votre
préférence c'est l'âge légal à 64 ans ou
64,2 et la durée de cotisation
cette note c'est l'âge moyen
mais à un moment il va falloir
à la retraite et là je moyens de départ
à la retraite il peut être obtenu de
diverses manières dont le déplacement de
l'âge légal absolument et des
incitations ou bien le fait qu'on
facilite
emploi retraite ou bien le fait qu'on
cherche d'autres voix de
soit en fait la durée soit on fait un
mix des deux choisir c'est exactement la
responsabilité de ceux qui sont élus et
vous avez d'un côté au gouvernement de
point de vue entre l'un des mécanismes
là je l'égal la durée de cotisation ou
un mix des deux les sons travailler le
Parlement mais vous voyez bien que moi
je pense que le
cette ce mixte existe et je pense
d'ailleurs que on évoque pas on en
parlant l'arme la plus puissante pour le
rééquilibrage des retraites c'est le
plein emploi on est actuellement à un
peu plus de 7% de chômage les pays qui
nous entourent l'Allemagne par exemple
sont à 3% de chômage parce que ça fait
aussi rentrer plus de cotisations le
plein emploi et donc si on a
2 millions de personnes de plus au
travail et bien le problème de
l'équilibre des retraites se pose de
manière complètement différente donc
plus de cotisations en revanche
augmenter les cotisations payées
individuellement est-ce que ça peut être
une graphiste elle a été écartée jusque
là pour moi vraiment la laisser de moi
non parce que
pourquoi il ne faut pas porter atteinte
c'est
la feuille de paix des salariés
je pense qu'il existe une piste que pour
l'instant le gouvernement est carte mais
qui moi me paraît pas totalement
inutile d'examiner c'est une légère
augmentation des cotisations retraite
des employeurs des entreprises légères
augmenteraient de quel ordre de grandeur
actuellement l'augmentation c'est 16,5
et le taux c'est 16,5 la masse salariale
comme cotisation retraite employeur je
pense qu'on pourrait passer à 17,5
et un point ça représente
0,7% de la masse salariale de la charge
ça permettrait d'aller un peu moins sur
l'âge et ça permettrait de trouver un
équilibre je encore une fois je
m'exprime là autant sur les chiffres que
nous avons établis
j'engage cette petite mais utile
institution qui est le plan autant quand
je parle de l'avenir je n'engage que
moi-même des intuitions vous avez parlé
les cotisations
pas directement mais ils ont ça en tête
bien sûr pour l'instant il l'écarte
complètement je pense qu'on ne trouvera
une solution que si on fait un mix de
plusieurs mesures
des mesures qui touchent à l'âge des
mesures qui touchent tout le travail
pour la productivité du pays vous savez
je vous donne les chiffres là encore
jusqu'à il y a 15 ans la productivité du
pays augmentait de 1,5% par an
et puis on est tombé à seulement 1% par
an il suffisait de remonter à 1,2 % par
an de productivité d'amélioration de
l'efficacité du pays et Dieu sait qui
est à faire avec l'organisation de
l'État avec l'organisation des
transports avec la SNCF avec le métro
tous les Français savent ce que je veux
dire avec l'État avec la difficulté pour
ne serait-ce que se faire faire
des passeports
trouver une productivité plus efficace
un pays plus efficace un pays qui marche
mieux un pays on serait sûr que les
transports la circulation mais c'est pas
pris en compte aujourd'hui dans la
réflexion sur la réforme et bien je
propose qu'on le prenne en compte je
propose qu'on prenne qu'on réfléchisse
à une solution qui permette de
rassembler tous les gens qui comprennent
qu'il faut faire quelque chose que ça
soit fait dans la transparence complète
et avoir les chiffres en main c'est la
transparence et preuve un peu
d'imagination vous voyez d'ici janvier
parce que je disais c'est 3 semaines et
demi avec les fêtes au milieu ça va
aller très vite est-ce que le
gouvernement est capable de pivoter à ce
point-là ça veut dire pivoter sur les
mesures d'âge accepter de considérer les
cotisations patronales et avoir une
vision plus macroéconomique
vous demandez beaucoup non je demande
pas beaucoup je demande que chacun
essaie de mettre
sa créativité son inventivité
et son sens civiques
à trouver un équilibre pour l'avenir des
retraites autrement quelle est la
solution c'est la baisse des pensions
plusieurs pays l'ont fait elle était
cartés par le gouvernement et il faut il
faut l'écarter avec
vigueur avec être intraitable sur ce
sujet parce que si nos compatriotes qui
sont à la retraite on le sentiment que
leur pension est menacée
alors ils sont pris d'un sentiment
d'insécurité et le sentiment
d'insécurité c'est ce qui a de pire pour
l'économie d'un pays il va y avoir aussi
François Bayrou pardon et vous avez
entendu oui le plein emploi vous dites
il faut prendre tout ça l'augmentation
de la productivité du pays vous avez des
clés qui sont aussi efficaces où doivent
être ajoutées pour trouver un équilibre
sur la réforme juste un point il va y
avoir aussi dans la mise en oeuvre une
question très importante c'est celle du
calendrier et du rythme auquel on va si
on augmente l'âge il faudra dire à quel
rythme on l'augmente est-ce que par
exemple avoir une borne qui serait 63
ans à la fin de ce quinquennat ça vous
paraît totalement inenvisageable c'est à
peu près dans l'ordre des choses ce qui
est prévu le président la veille excuse
en disant il y aura aucune hypothèse on
s'arrête à 63 ans au niveau de ce
quinquennat
au niveau de ce quinquennat parce que ça
veut dire continuer après bien sûr ce
qui a été dit c'est que les âges qui
sont évoqués 74 65 ans et tout le monde
se dit c'est pour demain matin non c'est
pour dans 10 ans alors le projet du
président c'était 65 ans 2031 mais en
étant 64 ans à la fin du quinquennat et
donc non mais c'est
progressif la réforme Touraine s'est
produit il y a pas de tabou pour dire on
sera 63 ans à la fin du quinquennat ça
peut être une borne sur le chemin vous
vous rendez bien compte que on est entré
dans une réforme très difficile et tout
le monde sait qu'elle est très difficile
on est entré dans une réforme qui va
mobiliser l'attention parfois
l'opposition de
beaucoup de force du pays c'est avec
toutes ses forces qu'on doit trouver une
solution d'équilibre je répète ce que
j'ai dit souvent et peut-être à votre
micro nous sommes co-responsables de
l'avenir
ceux qui sont dans la majorité ceux qui
sont en situation de responsabilité ceux
qui sont au gouvernement le président de
la République et les oppositions
tous ensemble et c'est l'avenir quel que
soit notre notre orientation nous sommes
correspondables de l'avenir est-ce que
entre ces co-responsables de l'avenir on
peut trouver quelque chose ou chacun se
disent bon on a fait un pas vers l'autre
je suis sûr qu'au bout du chemin vous
pouvez garder cet enregistrement au bout
du chemin dans quelques mois quand la
réforme aura été présentée qu'elle aura
été débattue qu'elle aura été amendée je
suis persuadé que c'est cet équilibre là
qu'il faudra trouver pour arriver à cela
François Bayrou il y a aussi la manière
dont on mène certes la concertation mais
ensuite la discussion parlementaire
dans un dîner à l'Élysée paraît-il il y
a quelques jours ont été évoqués deux
choses très importantes la possibilité
que cette réforme passe dans un
plfssr donc projet de loi de financement
la sécurité sociale rectificatif qui
donne droit donc à la possibilité de
recourir au 49.3 sur ce plateau au
lendemain de ce dîner or berger
président du groupe Renaissance a dit le
49,3 ce n'est pas un tabou vu ce que
vous venez de décrire les conditions de
dialogue est-ce que cette réforme de
votre point de vue peut être dans un
budget de la sécurité et peut passer par
49-39.3 c'est une arme institutionnelle
normale Michel Rocard
dont tout le monde se souvient qui était
pas
un dictateur a dû l'utiliser plusieurs
dizaines de fois c'est une arme de
violente par les oppositions de contre
nous parce que
il y a deux choses est-ce que on veut
qu'il y ait un débat la réponse est oui
je pense que le Parlement dans sa
configuration actuelle le Parlement
exige le la situation les équilibres
exige qu'il y ait un débat ce débat peut
prendre le temps nécessaire il s'agit
pas de brusquer il s'agit pas d'empêcher
le débat au terme du processus
si on s'aperçoit qu'il n'y a pas de
majorité
mais que au fond un certain nombre de
forces acceptent que
le gouvernement fasse son travail et que
on est une réforme des retraites qui
sera je le crois le résultat de
départ réciproques que les hommes
peuvent
ce jour-là le 49.3 c'est on vient d'en
vivre combien 9 de suite c'est les mains
c'est une arme parlementaire normale
mais il faut que le débat ait lieu et
notamment que le débat est lieux à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat vous
dites si le débat YouTube que le Sénat a
adopté un amendement qui est pas très
très loin de ce qui est examiné
aujourd'hui porté par la droite en
l'occurrence avec un peu dash légal et
un peu de durée de cotisation c'est et
qui est franchement dans la même
philosophie une bonne inspiration de
votre point de vue en tout cas
j'ai toujours été persuadé que une
démocratie ça consistait à prendre en
compte des voix qui sont pas les vôtres
des sensibilités qui sont pas les vôtres
et à faire en sorte qu'on puisse
s'accorder donc il faut écouter cette
voix sur des décisions à prendre vous
avez évoqué un point très important tout
à l'heure c'est notre situation
budgétaire et le poids que représente
les retraites là-dedans il y a quand
même une question qui n'est pas encore
bien clair pour tout le monde c'est
est-ce que cette réforme elle sert à
équilibrée le système de retraite point
ou à équilibrer le système de retraite
plus financer d'autres politiques
d'autres priorités le gouvernement a eu
les deux discours sur ce plateau Gabriel
Attal par exemple avait dit ça peut
servir à financer d'autres politiques et
lundi Geoffroy route Bézieux à votre
place dit hors de question le système de
retraite c'est pour les retraites
et les deux phrases si j'ose dire disent
la même chose
lorsque vous avez un régime de ou un
système de retraite il y a 42 régimes ce
qui est d'ailleurs dingue si vous
réfléchissez une seconde est-ce que
c'est l'occasion de supprimer les
régimes spéciaux cette réforme et on a
oublié le le pas en avant qui était
celui de la discussion précédente qui
peut aller à son terme 42 régimes si
vous regardez ce système de retraite et
que vous apercevez qu'il est financé
tous les ans par des dizaines de
milliards de déficits et de dettes le
rééquilibrer c'est rendre service à la à
l'ensemble de l'équilibre budgétaire du
pays et ça ne sera pas pour faire autre
chose ça sera pour rééquilibrer oui donc
vous dites c'est quand même pour
équilibrer le système de retraite et ça
allégera le poids global rééquilibrer le
système de retraite c'est rééquilibré le
budget du pays
si le budget du pays est obligé de
donner 30 milliards tous les ans alors
effectivement ça pèse sous forme de
déficit et de dette rééquilibrer le
régime de retraite c'est rendre non pas
des marges de manœuvre mais un peu plus
d'équilibre au budget du pays encore
deux sujets d'actualité avant qu'on
arrive à la fin de cet entretien vous
regardez forcément ce qui se passe à
l'Assemblée nationale pas sur le fond
mais sur la forme avec un député Adrien
cadenas qui a été condamné hier à 4 mois
de prison avec sursis pour la gifle et
les messages envoyés à son épouse il a
été radié par son groupe pour 4 mois
mais il une question très simple qui se
posent bon la démission à la limite
mettons l'autre côté parce que les
électeurs l'entélisme c'est un fait mais
est-ce qu'il faut changer la loi pour
que désormais ce type de violence
entraîne automatiquement une énigibilité
une impossibilité de sierger est-ce
qu'il y a là un problème à régler alors
s'il n'y a pas eu une illigibilité c'est
que les juges ont choisi qu'il n'y ait
pas inéligibilité c'est une peine
accessoire qu'ils auraient très bien pu
déclencher alors un je déteste les
chasse à l'homme
et donc je n'y participe là il y en a
une de votre point de vue comment
dirais-je une
rassemblement de
d'accusation d'attaques
ce qui ne me paraît pas normal et à la
place de Adrien katas je réfléchirai à
ça c'est de dire je ne siège pas mais je
suis payé quand même
je trouve que pour pour ceux qui le
regardent
j'en parle avec prudence parce que
derrière il va revenir si j'ai cette
situation là il y a aussi des tragédies
personnelles
une femme en avance pour les pouces qui
étaient frappés
mal c'est j'aime pas parler de ça
légèrement mais
accepter d'être payé alors qu'on ne
siège pas ce qu'il a ces derniers mois
mais qu'elle souhaitait revenir
qui me semble-t-il ne va pas tout
dernier mot ce soir demi-finale la
France face au Maroc un pronostic le
président sera sur place d'ailleurs ça
suscite beaucoup de réactions politiques
votre pronostic pour ce match moi je
crois que la France devrait gagner 3
mais il en est des pronostics comme des
annonces pour la météo dans plusieurs
mois et ben on va justement aller sur la
météo la vraie celle d'aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup François Bayrou merci d'avoir